so for all three of you I mean one of
one of the great and memorable scenes in
the film there are there are many but
but the iconic coffee shop meeting the
people were so struck by when the film
came out seeing two such great actors
who had not acted in the same scene
together before together there was such
Mythology around at the time I remember
several friends of mine being convinced
that it shot it on different days
because there was no two shot well hey
when I finally moved the move to LA and
went to Capeman Delaney's was shot at I
was pleased as he there is a two-shot it
was above the door of Kate Maddalena's
are still from the film but I'd love to
hear I'm sure people here would love to
hear about shooting that scene was it
single camera was it two cameras did you
have two cameras so you could shoot both
close-ups at the same time how did how
did you approach that that momentous
event it started with with consummate
respect and for the great artists that
these two guys are and we didn't we
talked about the scene and we analyzed
the scene we kind of read the cringe
better off the page a little but we
didn't want to do the scene until we
were at gay manliness and then the it
was so ingrained that I knew that the
innocent little tiny organic details it
would be different from take to tank so
what I wanted to do was shoot with two
cameras two over the shoulders and then
I also had a second thought camera they
were shooting a profile that never we
never cut into the film and so I knew
that there have been organic unity to
one take and to be a slightly different
organic unity to another because if you
look at it very carefully if Bob shifts
his hand like this a little bit right in
the middle of dialogue L is doing
something to counter it because maybe
he's shifting his positions that he can
get closer to a weapon and it was just
this back and forth so most of the most
of the scene is all take eleven take 11
take 11 I know it's it's that that 20
years later I actually remember is that
11
well I remember is that he wanted to
Michael shot one way and and then all of
a sudden said should we turn around and
go this way and I said wait a minute we
just shot like one take possibly two
this way and then it was like oh god it
was physically I thought you can say you
remembering take 18 and I'd say no what
do you remember about that that shoot I
do remember that a bob said I thought
really at first I wondered about it and
then I thought how right he is because
he said that's not worship so as you
love to rehearse oh yeah as soon as Bob
does - well I like I do too at times but
this kind of the scene we've yeah I
didn't have to know it but you did the
thing is it what Bob said it's so true
about where or so might think if there's
any actors out there it's one of the
things I really admire and I follow and
that is that there is no sense in
rehearsing if the people around you and
you and I don't know how to rehearse
that is that is an important factor my
zone that were us or us very little but
it's true you know because it's a
certain kind of thing and people either
respond to it or they don't and so they
could be great actress of course but
they don't want to rehearse and I've had
experiences like that Bob though did
this particularly I think for this the
nature of this filming us was also that
we were stationary so it wasn't we had
the two sort of a hearse blocking or
anything and discover how our physical
moves were kind of there though there
was subtle moves in the scene itself
obviously but anyway and we started late
and
we started late at Michaels you know we
were her we went through it kind of
blocked it but didn't by the way I
remember maybe I remember correctly but
we didn't start till after lunch or
dinner which is really like 1 o'clock in
the morning so and this was like I loved
the scene and I wanted you know was
really wanted to be as best as it could
be so I was a little unhappy that we
started so late in the middle of the
night but anyway we did and it was fine
the ex was actually intentional to just
kind of I know he wanted to tire us out
going into scene like that that you know
is gonna be such a significant part the
film huge expectation from both of you
as you sit down to perform it at the end
of that night did you know you had it
did you feel it I never know that I
never know III knew it I knew we had it
oh I know you do that's your job by the
way we rehearse you like to do it again
yeah reshoot we don't we normally would
rehearse since that scene we talked
about we all this a group decided you
know we want to just talk it through and
to save it for the you know for the
event of shooting it which was the only
scene we probably did that with but I
tend to not want to rehearse things to
the point where I feel like I wish I'd
shot it that's a disaster I always
wanted to take it I always want to stop
well short of because I think things
will be perfect once and you'll they'll
never be perfect you know don't ever be
100% twice the owing 100% once you want
that happening in front of camera